elles sont partout depuis le début du
mois 13 caméras quadrillent le quartier
du tennis au creusot face à la
recrudescence des incivilités des actes
de délinquance et des trafics
la municipalité a voulu reprendre les
choses en main après le citoyen il
demande pas forcément des caméras ou
tout autre dispositif ce qu'il veut
c'est que il y est il y ait un phénomène
qu'ils soient éradiquées ensuite c'est à
nous de trouver les moyens
encore une fois collectivement depuis
plusieurs mois le trafic de drogue s'est
intensifiée dans ce quartier creusotin
début octobre un coup de fil et permet
l'arrestation de plusieurs têtes du
réseau criminel
l'installation des caméras surtout pour
objectif de faciliter le futur travail
des enquêteurs
on n'est pas naïfs c'est un long travail
donc il faut poursuivre les efforts il y
a encore eu des arrestations après ce
gros coup de filet il y en aura sans
doute encore parce que la pression va
être maintenue sur l'ensemble du
quartier
ici au quartier du tennis impossible
d'obtenir de témoignages devant notre
caméra parler ouvertement est impossible
les quelques habitants que nous avons pu
rencontrer juge cependant le dispositif
insuffisant selon eux les trafics
continuerai aussi hors du périmètre de
ce dispositif de protection vidéo
seul point positif selon les habitants
les récentes arrestations du mois
dernier aurait ramené un peu de calme
dans le quartier